صباح الانوار قرطاج مرحبا صباح الانوار
ايام قرطاج للفن المعاصر تعود من جديد هنا
في مدينه الثقافه التونسيه
رجعت من جديد ايام قرطاج الفن المعاصر بعد
احتجاب انطلق منذ ازمه كورونا تعود اليوم
ضيف هذه الدوره هي دوله فلسطين وانطلقت
الفعاليات وسط حضور محترم ومحترم جدا
للمشاركين للمره الاولى كما قلنا بعد ازمه
كورونا
طيب هذا الموضوع الاول موضوعنا الثاني
زراعي على ما يبدو خلينا نشوف شو تفاصيله
يا احلام
ام لم بالفعل الزراعه المستدامه هي احد
انواع الزراعه الزراعه المستدامه
هي تصدي لازمه المناخ وكذلك للجفاف
الزراعه المستدامه تعتمد على مجموعه من
المعطيات العلميه التي تمكن من الحفاظ على
الثروات وكذلك الحفاظ على المناخ وضمان
التعادل في التوزيع في ثروات ما بين
الفلاحين
يعيشك احلام العبدليه من تونس راح نكون
معك باخبار جديده كل يوم شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات